one of the concerns for putin is
uh a lot of the countries that were part
of ussr are now
part of nato and it's 13 surrounding
countries that are part of nato
surrounding russia that are not part of
nato so to him
that's a threat because nato keeps
getting stronger around lithuania
and yugoslavia
although the eastern bloc yeah i mean
just take these guys right and he's
sitting there saying what is nato's
vision what are you trying to do are you
trying to control me are you trying to
hold me
you know those are the nations right
estonia latvia lithuania poland czech
slovakia hungary romania slovenia uh
croatia montenegro all right on their
doorstep right there so he's kind of
like sitting there saying what is going
on here so
then you look at the history
where years ago stalin negotiated a
treaty with hitler to prevent hitler
from invading
through ukraine that was kind of like
the arrangement that they had but
germany broke its promise and attacked
russia anyways
launching barbarossa which ended up
being the largest military operation at
the time and at one point
with ukraine this is why nazi keeps
coming up at one point ukraine was
aligned with hitler
and sss i mean with them in 1941 80 000
people from the ukraine ukrainian army
fought for hitler's army yes so this is
the part that gets a little tricky with
what you know putin's kind of like do
you guys know the history of what's
going on what what do you know about
this all right rich history let me let
me please go a few years prior to that
happening you're you're right on target
here and uh quite frankly uh this is not
being discussed in the media at all it's
like i heard it i forgot the name i
heard a senator the other day
saying something like ukraine has been a
democracy
for the last 30 years that's not true
it was an oligarchy
and it's still very corrupt today it's
not a democracy
so but let me go back to history um
in
ukraine
beca was sort of annexed by
i think i think it was still under linen
and became part of the soviet union
uh
there
was always and there have always been a
two uh
populations uh in in ukraine there was a
russian speaking and ukrainian speaking
and the ukrainians were more to on the
polish side
so anyway so the the western ukrainians
uh there was a separatist movement they
wanted to go get away from the soviet
union
the other thing that happened in
and
that's very interesting the
collectivization
of the agriculture of the soviet union
you know peasants don't like to be
collectivized
they
they they want to own land right
and once you take that land away from
them you take you know their way of life
so there was this phenomenal amount of
resistance and so stalin
found a way to uh
uh starve them into submission he
and they were mostly kgb agents and some
others that went into ukraine and stole
all the grain for two years
they were uh
and so the folks that actually
uh planted the grain and harvested it uh
had nothing to eat there were four
million
ukrainians that starved to death
in those days
that is
the reason for the phenomenal hatred
that ukrainians have today
uh vis-a-vis
the russians even though stalin wasn't a
russian but you know hatred is not
rational
it was hatred against something that
came from the east
and um and so as a result
when hitler came in
uh there were enough ukrainians thought
uh who thought you know there was
liberation
it didn't turn out that way but you're
right there were about 80 000 folks that
that uh
fought on in hitler's army there were uh
guards in concentration camps ukrainians
who
who committed lots of atrocities the
most uh the most uh infamous nationalist
was steppan bandera
uh anti-communist he was you know and it
was pro-freedom to the point where
he he he pissed a lot of people off well
he was also anti-semitic yeah he was and
and and they hated russians that much
and they decided to side with the nazis
but the enemy of my enemy is my friend
basically exactly but but they were also
fundamentally evil
and so when putin says you know there's
there's nazis in in
in
ukraine there's something to it uh
and in
2019 ukraine issued commemorative stamps
to honor the 100th birthday of bandera
that's not a good sign
so there are some that's what i'm saying
there's some stuff that the history that
people
i don't know if enough proper
investigative journalism has been done
to know what's going on there's some
guys that are doing it right now but
this anti-semitism is all over oh yeah
especially eastern europe eastern europe
absolutely
but you know
but do you know this guy this stephen
bandera guy you know who put him in jail
you know who put him in jail during
world war ii
germany hitler put him in jail yes i
mean
oh because he was getting two he was too
independent yeah he was too independent
and they feared him so they just
straight up put him in jail and from
jail
he was still inspiring and moving people
from jail he was jailed he was still
sending messages out to people so this
this guy right here if you look at the
screen i don't know if david you can
show it or not
he played a very very big role uh during
that time but i'm sorry continue well
bottom line is i
there there are there's fascist
nazi ideologies still in ukraine but
it's not prevalent
you know what we have there there's a
really really good book uh that was
written by
uh sean walker
who was the correspondent uh for for the
guardian in moscow and he traveled all
over the country and the book was called
the the long hangover it's about russia
of today and he goes into the russian uh
and uh and ukrainian uh
the relationship
and based on sean's writing that there
are no good people
on either side now that book came out in
2019 that was before zielinski was
elected
i think he's a good guy
well if i may
you know the whole
propaganda that putin is using is that
he's going into ukraine to free ukraine
of
nazism that's right the ironic part
about it is zielinski the president of
ukraine is jewish
the first jewish president they've ever
had i believe and also the number two
person the prime minister is also jewish
so it's like i'm trying to draw an
analogy that you're saying of course
there's anti-semites in ukraine i'm sure
that's everywhere that's like saying
there's racists in america but we
elected barack obama so
there's always going to be bad actors in
every country yeah but what they're
talking about is the fact that ukraine
flips so much from pro-russia
pro-western pro-you eu pro-russia
pro-western pro-dis so you know seems to
be like half and half though if you're
closer to the russian side you're gonna
be more pro-russian if you're closer to
the polish side or the eu side you're
gonna be more
democratic you have the battle of the
victors you know the two victors that
went at it right victor uh
uh yoshkanov uh yochenko and then victor
uh uh pronouncing it yanukovych okay
those two went at it so
uh
his wife was on reagan's administration
okay yeah his wife american yes was on
reagan's i don't know if she's american
but she was on reagan's administration
okay
so and then on the other side with
uh uh yanukovych he was more on the
other side he was more pro russia he was
more let's make it work so
the whole documentary with winner on
fire that sean penn talks about these
kids are all excited students are
excited you know the victor that's on
pro russia site said we're going to sign
this treaty with eu we're going to sign
this treaty we're going to do this and
then also last one they're like no we're
not doing it
and then last minute we flipped and then
they're not doing it so that led to the
protesting which led to ugly
i don't know if you saw these it was
pretty bad with the protesting and the
writing
and then eventually they get this guy on
uh where pope francis comes out and
prays for ukraine on january 26th
of 2014 very interesting at the end of
his prayer they let two doves go okay
very it's a little creepy if you watch
this
they let two doves go when these two
doves are flying no joke a crow and a
seagull attacks the two dove get out of
here and the audience is there like
panicking because it's all symbolism
right everything's over there's about
symbolism they're like oh my gosh and
they're going back and forth back and
forth back and forth then eventually the
seagulls and the crow leaves which means
that symbolized
before things get better you're going to
make it you're going to survive but
before things get better
you're going to get attacked by kronos
eagles so that's
how some of the folks there take that as
you know things can get pretty ugly and
then after that january 24th to january
26th was the day when poke give that
message
february 24th is when they fulfilled
their coup
victor was kicked out victor called uh
putin putin said you can come and he
went to russia and that's where it was
at and then next thing you know zalinski
shows up in 2019 2020 yeah and you're
saying he's a good agent so if you
enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you're not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]